so my friend sent me this text message
yesterday apparently the whole world is
playing a Kardashian game Kardashian
game oh it's just Kim's game I thought
it was all of them okay downloading do I
do a dude is there a point what's the
point of playing Kim Kardashian game if
I'm going to be a dude appreciate the
fact that there are three shades of
denim available everything that is spelt
with a C is spelt with decay you need to
start doing crossovers I want to buy
Kanye swag before you're famous you were
new to Hollywood like this is futile
life there would be a sex tape portion
and a casting couch what am i doing why
how did I get here
today like what am i okay yeah I'm late
for an appointment to look at I'm just
accepting this like this is a normal
thing I'm like reading this like this a
[ __ ] Bible straightened shirt money
who money came out when I get that money
what do I just get it am i a retail
worker Oh Kim just got here Kim Kim
doesn't seem to have much going on in
this game Kim please she just wants
someone to listen tell me to wait for
Simon's call about a special gig no
needs to chill out they want me to do
photo shoots they want me to do events
they want me to do these tasks and I'm
running out of energy like willow Pape
is my nemesis that's weird because she's
going off about you and Kim on every
social media outlet whatever I must to
famous to deal with you trash hashtag
ratchet whoa reach the next level you
can now travel I have to level up and
now I'm allowed to travel to Beverly
Hills before like it's like don't show
can face in Beverly Hills but now I have
the appropriate Klout level eight and
you go to Calabasas legal to do what
become a suburban mom
Hollywood is super easy this is really
inspiring actually I'm gonna play this
game a lot a lot I I think that you
ruined my life
[ __ ] it's just asked to like it on
Facebook and I did